Nietzsche pensaba que los humanos éramos los únicos animales que ríen.
De hecho, existe la risa en los mamíferos.
Ha sido bien descrita y observada en primates,
pero también en ratas,
y dondequiera que la veamos
-- humanos, primates, ratas --
la asociamos a cosas como las cosquillas.
Es lo mismo en los humanos.
Se la asocia con el juego, y todos los mamíferos juegan.
Siempre que se la encuentra, se la asocia con las interacciones.
Robert Provine, que investigó mucho este tema,
señaló que somos 30 veces más propensos a reír
si estamos con compañía que si estamos solos,
y que la risa está más presente
en interacciones sociales como la conversación.
Si le preguntamos a alguien: "¿Cuándo ríes?"
Dirán con una comedia, con el humor, con los chistes.
Si observamos cuándo ríen, ríen con sus amigos.
Y si nos reímos con las personas, difícilmente sea de chistes.
Nos reímos para mostrar a las personas que uno las entiende,
que está de acuerdo con ellas, que uno es parte del grupo.
Nos reímos para mostrar que a uno le agradan.
Uno quizá los ame.
Uno hace todo eso mientras les habla,
y la risa expresa todas esas emociones por uno.
Es algo que señaló Robert Provine, como pueden ver aquí,
y es la razón por la cual reímos
al escuchar esas risas graciosas al principio,
y por la que yo reí al descubrir a mis padres riendo,
y ese es un enorme efecto de comportamiento contagioso.
Uno puede contagiarse la risa de otro,
y es más probable contagiarse la risa si ese otro es alguien conocido.
Por eso todavía es modulada por este contexto social.
Añadamos humor en un lado
y pensemos en el sentido social de la risa
porque allí yace su origen.
Me interesan mucho los distintos tipos de risas
y tenemos evidencias neurobiológicas de cómo vocalizamos los humanos
que sugieren que podríamos tener 2 tipos de risas.
Parece posible que la neurobiología de la risa involuntaria e inevitable,
como la de mis padres en el suelo riendo por una canción tonta,
podría tener una base distinta que la risa social más educada
que encontramos, y no es una risa horrible,
sino que responde al comportamiento de alguien que se comunica con uno,
es parte de su interacción con uno; eligen hacer eso.
En la evolución, hemos desarrollado dos maneras distintas de vocalizar.
Las vocalizaciones involuntarias son parte de un sistema más antiguo
que las vocalizaciones más voluntarias como esta charla que doy ahora.
Podemos imaginar que la risa tiene dos raíces distintas.
He estudiado esto en más detalle.
Para esto, he grabado a las personas riendo,
y hemos hecho de todo para que se rían,
y hemos hecho que esas mismas personas produzcan una risa social más forzada.
Imaginen que un amigo les cuenta un chiste,
y Uds. se ríen porque aprecian a su amigo
pero no por el chiste.
Les pondré un par de esas risas.
Quiero que me digan si son risas reales,
o si piensan que son forzadas.
Estas risas ¿son involuntarias o más voluntarias?
(Audio: Risas)
¿Qué les parece ese sonido?
Público: Forzada. Sophie Scott: ¿Forzada? Forzada.
¿Y este sonido?
(Audio: Risas)
(Risas)
Soy la mejor.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
En realidad no.
No, esa era una risa inevitable,
y, de hecho, para grabarla solo tuvieron que grabarme
viendo a una de mis amigas escuchar algo que sabía le haría gracia,
y empecé a hacer esto.
Podemos ver que somos buenos para notar la diferencia
entre la risa real y la forzada.
Nos parecen cosas diferentes.
Curiosamente, vemos algo bastante similar en los chimpancés.
Los chimpancés ríen diferente si les hacen cosquillas
que si se ríen jugando unos con otros,
y puede que veamos algo así aquí,
la risa involuntaria, la de cosquillas, es diferente de la risa social.
Acústicamente son muy diferentes.
Las risas reales son más prolongadas. Son más agudas.
Cuando empiezas a reír con fuerza,
empiezas a expulsar aire de los pulmones
con mucha más fuerza de la que ejercemos voluntariamente.
Por ejemplo, yo no podría cantar con una voz tan alta.
Además, empezamos a hacer contracciones y silbidos extraños,
lo que implica que la risa verdadera es muy fácil,
podemos detectarla fácilmente.
Por el contrario, la riza forzada, podríamos pensar que suena un poco falsa.
En realidad no lo es, es una señal social importante.
La usamos mucho, elegimos reír en muchas situaciones,
y parece tener entidad propia.
Por ejemplo, observamos nasalidad en la risa forzada,
ese sonido tipo "ja, ja, ja, ja, ja"
un sonido que no podríamos hacer con la risa involuntaria.
Por lo que parecen ser genuinamente dos tipos de risas diferentes.
Las llevamos al escáner para ver cómo responde el cerebro
al escuchar las risas.
Hacer esto es un experimento realmente aburrido.
Le pusimos a las personas risas reales y forzadas.
No les dijimos que era un estudio sobre la risa.
Les pusimos otros sonidos para distraerlos;
todos están allí oyendo sonidos.
No les pedimos que hagan nada.
Sin embargo, al oír risas reales y risas forzadas
el cerebro responde de forma totalmente diferente
significativamente diferente.
Lo que ven en las zonas de azul, que cae en la corteza auditiva,
son las zonas del cerebro que responden más a la risa real,
que parece ser el caso
al oír a alguien reír involuntariamente,
uno oye sonidos que nunca oiría en otro contexto.
Es muy nítido
y parece estar asociado a un mayor procesamiento auditivo
de estos nuevos sonidos.
Por el contrario, al oír a alguien riendo de manera forzada,
se observan estas zonas en rosa,
que ocupan zonas del cerebro asociadas a la mentalización,
a pensar en lo que otra persona está pensando.
Y pienso que eso significa
que incluso si nos escanean el cerebro, algo totalmente aburrido,
algo no muy interesante,
al oír a alguien haciendo "Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja",
uno se pregunta por qué se ríe.
La risa siempre tiene significado.
Siempre tratamos de entenderla en contexto,
incluso si, en lo que a uno respecta, en ese momento,
no tiene necesariamente nada que ver con uno,
siempre querremos saber por qué la gente se ríe.
También hemos podido observar cómo las personas oyen risas reales y forzadas
en todo el rango de edad.
Este es un experimento en línea que hicimos con la Royal Society,
donde hicimos 2 preguntas.
Primero, oyeron algunas risas,
y tuvieron que decir cuán reales o forzadas sonaban esas risas.
Las risas reales aparecen en rojo y las forzadas en azul.
Se ve que hay un inicio rápido.
Conforme envejecemos, hay una mejor detección de la risa real.
Los niños de 6 años ríen al azar, no pueden oír la diferencia.
Conforme envejecemos, mejoramos,
pero, curiosamente, no llegamos al máximo rendimiento
hasta finales de los 30, principios de los 40.
Uno no entiende plenamente la risa en la pubertad.
Uno no entiende plenamente la risa cuando el cerebro ha madurado
al final de la pubertad.
Aprendemos sobre la risa durante toda la vida temprana de adulto.
Si cambiamos la pregunta y en vez de decir cómo suena la risa
en términos de real o forzada, y en cambio decimos
cuántas ganas de reír te da esta risa,
cuán contagiosa te resulta esta risa, vemos un perfil diferente.
Aquí, cuando más joven es uno,
más quiere sumarse a la risa.
Recuerden mi risa con mis padres cuando no tenía idea de qué pasaba.
Realmente pueden ver esto.
Todos, jóvenes y ancianos,
encuentran la risa real más contagiosa que la risa forzada,
pero conforme envejecemos, todo se vuelve menos contagioso.
O perdemos el humor con los años,
o entendemos mejor la risa,
y nos volvemos tan buenos en eso,
que necesitamos más que oír una risa para querer reír.
Necesitamos el aspecto social.
Tenemos un comportamiento muy interesante
sobre el cual tenemos muchas presunciones incorrectas,
pero encuentro que la risa es mucho más
que una emoción social importante que deberíamos observar
porque resulta que las personas expresan muchos matices
en el uso de la risa.
Hay unos estudios encantadores
de Robert Levenson en California,
son estudios longitudinales con parejas.
Él lleva parejas casadas, hombres y mujeres, al laboratorio
y les da conversaciones estresantes
y les coloca un polígrafo para verlos estresarse.
Tiene allí a los dos y le dice al marido:
"Cuéntame algo que haga tu mujer que a ti te irrite".
Y se observa de inmediato...
--imaginen eso un instante, Uds. y su pareja--
es de suponer que todo se pone más tenso cuando esto empieza.
Se ven reacciones físicas, las personas se tensan.
Él encuentra que las parejas que manejan esa tensión
con risa, con emociones positivas como la risa,
no solo están menos tensas de inmediato,
sino que puede verse que físicamente se sienten mejor,
y enfrentan mejor esta situación desagradable, juntos,
son también las parejas que tienen
altos niveles de satisfacción en sus relaciones
y permanecen juntos más tiempo.
De hecho, al estudiar relaciones cercanas
la risa es un índice extraordinariamente útil
de cómo las personas regulan sus emociones juntas.
No solo la emitimos unos a otros para mostrar aprecio mutuo,
sino que buscamos sentirnos mejor juntos.
No creo que esto se limite a las relaciones románticas.
Creo que quizá es una característica
de las relaciones afectivas cercanas como las amistades
que explican mi próximo clip,
un video de YouTube de unos jóvenes de la antigua Alemania del Este
que hacían un video para promocionar su banda de heavy metal.
Es muy machista y el ambiente es muy serio.
Y quiero que noten qué ocurre en materia de risas
cuando algo sale mal,
lo rápido que sucede, y cómo cambia el humor.
Tiene frío. Está a punto de mojarse. Tiene el traje de baño,
tiene una toalla.
Hay hielo.
¿Qué podría pasar?
Empieza el video.
Seriedad.
Sus amigos ya se están riendo. Se ríen con ganas.
Todavía no ríe.
(Risas)
Empieza a reírse.
Y ahora que están todos riendo.
(Risas)
Están en el suelo.
Lo que me gusta de esto es que todo es muy serio
hasta que salta al hielo y tan pronto como no atraviesa el hielo
pero tampoco hay sangre ni huesos por todas partes,
sus amigos empiezan a reír.
Imaginen si ocurriera eso con él allí diciendo:
"No, en serio, Heinrich, creo que me rompí algo",
no disfrutaríamos al verlo. Nos pondría tensos.
Tampoco si corriese por allí riendo con una fractura expuesta,
y sus amigos dijeran: "Heinrich, creo que tenemos que ir al hospital ahora",
eso tampoco sería gracioso.
La risa funciona porque
lo saca de una situación dolorosa, embarazosa y difícil
y lo pone en una situación graciosa que disfrutamos
y creo que es un uso muy interesante
que ocurre todo el tiempo.
Por ejemplo, recuerdo que pasó algo así
en el funeral de mi padre.
No estábamos saltando en el hielo en calzoncillos.
No somos canadienses.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Son eventos siempre difíciles, tenía un pariente un poco difícil,
mi madre no estaba en un buen lugar,
y recuerdo encontrarme justo antes de que todo empezara
contando la historia de algo ocurrido en una comedia de 1970,
y pensé en ese momento, no sé por qué estoy haciendo esto,
y me di cuenta de que
sacaba algo de algún sitio
que podía usar para hacerla reír conmigo.
Fue una reacción muy básica encontrar alguna razón para hacerlo.
Podemos reír juntas. Vamos a superar esto.
Vamos a estar bien.
De hecho, todos nosotros lo hacemos todo el tiempo.
Lo hacemos tan a menudo, que no lo notamos.
Todos subestimamos todo lo que reímos
y hacemos algo al reír con la gente,
nos permite acceder a un sistema evolutivo muy antiguo
que los mamíferos hemos evolucionado para crear y mantener vínculos sociales
claramente para regular emociones, que nos hagan sentir mejor.
No es algo específico de los humanos; es un comportamiento muy antiguo
que nos ayuda a regular cómo nos sentimos y nos hace sentir mejor.
En otras palabras, en materia de risas,
tú y yo, bebé, no somos más que mamíferos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)